Outside of Philadelphia,
there is an old nursing home
that peaks out from behind lush trees.
Instead of caring for the old,
these days, it detains the young.
Kids who came to the United States
with their parents.
Inside its hallways,
a little boy named Diego
went from diapers to detention.
When he was just one year old,
Diego's mother, Wendy, decided
that life in Honduras was too dangerous
for them to stay.
Like people from all over the world
have done for generations,
Diego and Wendy turned
to the United States for safety.
If you are in the United States
and you are afraid for your life,
federal law is clear
that you can ask for asylum.
It does not matter where you came from
or how you got here.
Diego and Wendy did just that.
Within a few days,
they found themselves inside
that Pennsylvania immigration prison.
Two among half a million people
who will be locked up every single year,
while the government decides
if they will be allowed to stay
in the United States.
Instead of a fair match
between a prosecutor
and a defense attorney,
imprisoned migrants
usually walk into court alone.
It's a high-stakes legal battle
that they are forced to fight
with their hands tied behind their backs.
As the courts deliberate, the days pass.
From your community to mine,
today, someone is locked up
who has not been accused of any crime.
Often, they haven't seen a judge
or even a lawyer.
And yet, in most immigration prisons
that I have visited
as a lawyer or a researcher,
the steel door is closed shut
with the clink of confinement.
For the sake of votes,
politicians claim people like Diego
and Wendy are dangerous, or dishonest.
For the sake of profits,
private corporations
run prisons to house them.
It seems unimaginable today,
but we haven't always locked up migrants
who are waiting for the government
to decide their fate.
At one time,
the United States stood on the verge
of abolishing immigration prisons.
"This was the sign
of an enlightened civilization,"
the Supreme Court wrote in 1958.
We were so close.
But politics and profits pushed us
in the opposite direction.
With the support
of Republicans and Democrats,
today, we lock up men,
we lock up women, and we lock up children.
But in our past,
I see hope for the future.
We can take clear steps
toward abolishing immigration prisons.
Most people think of Ellis Island
as the place that welcomed generations
of newcomers to the United States.
It did that,
but it was also an immigration prison
with an ironic view
of the Statue of Liberty.
By the 1950s, the Ellis Island facility
needed to be repaired,
replaced or discarded.
The government of the war hero
turned Republican president,
Dwight Eisenhower,
decided to shut it down.
But then, starting in the late 1970s,
the United States built the largest
immigration prison system in the world.
Republicans and Democrats worked together,
pointing to the prison's barbed wire
to uphold the law to protect you ...
from me.
When Haitians started arriving
in large numbers in the 1970s,
Carter turned to detention.
In the 1980s, Reagan followed
by jailing Cubans and Central Americans.
George H. W. Bush turned
to the military base at Guantanamo, Cuba,
to jail migrants.
President Clinton left them there.
This isn't a partisan issue.
This is a profits issue.
To local governments
and private businesses,
immigration prisons
are a financial spigot.
The two largest private prison
corporations in the United States,
CoreCivic and the GEO Group,
get about half of their money
from the federal government.
With that, they hire people
in out-of-the-way locations,
where decent-paying jobs
are hard to come by.
Down in South Texas,
head north from the border,
and eventually, you will catch
the sharp stench of onions
filling the air.
The local economy of Raymondville --
that's the county seat
of Willacy County --
it runs on produce --
on produce and on prisons.
Tucked behind a state jail,
the Willacy County Detention Center
houses federal immigration prisoners
in large canvas tents.
A few years ago, this facility shut down,
after inmates rebelled.
And when that happened,
I was not surprised,
because back when I used
to represent clients there,
stories of rape, harassment
and abuse were common.
Eventually, the county
lost a few hundred jobs.
Even the Walmart shut down.
But then, in the summer of 2018,
when the refurbished prison
was ramping up to reopen,
the county's elected officials celebrated.
Why was the county so interested?
It owned the prison,
and the private company just ran it.
Having prisoners on the inside
meant that the private company
could hire guards,
and it could hire nurses,
and it meant that the county
could pay its bills.
With support from Washington
down to Willacy County,
it's a good time to be in the business
of locking up migrants.
But we can't forget that these are people
who we're talking about,
from kids who are too young
to be asked their opinions,
to adults with longtime ties
to the United States.
Diego and Wendy were stuck inside
that old nursing home turned prison,
waiting for the legal process
to slowly grind forward.
Just one when he arrived,
Diego was three by the time he got out.
Eventually, he won his legal case
to stay in the United States,
but not before 650 nights passed.
And yet ...
others are not so lucky.
Kamyar Samimi ...
had a green card
and 40 years in the United States,
when one day, ICE showed up at his door
and took him down to a private prison
in suburban Denver.
Within 13 days,
he was dead.
The government
never got around to deciding
if he should be deported.
In this topsy-turvy world,
we feel better when we lock up
kids with their mothers,
or when people don’t meet
the same end as Mr. Samimi.
Is this really the best that we can do?
The path to a world
that's free of immigration prisons
does not begin by pretending
that migrants are perfect.
It starts with a reality check.
Immigration law tells us
that migrants are aliens.
But we all know
that migrants are not aliens.
Migrants are just people.
And like most people,
most of the time,
migrants are profoundly ordinary --
ordinary people
asked to do the extraordinary:
wage your final fight
to stay in this country
while you are locked up
far away from family, your friends --
where lawyers are hard to come by.
To fix this and move toward a world
without immigration prisons,
let's stop paying
CoreCivic and the GEO Group
to lock up migrants,
and let's start paying lawyers
to defend them.
(Cheers and applause)
Having a lawyer just means that the courts
are more likely to reach
a fair and a just conclusion.
And when it comes
to important legal questions,
let's be honest,
what's more American
that a fight between lawyers?
(Laughter)
And we've done this in the past.
The government has run
several pilot projects.
Every time, support has proven enough
to get migrants out of prison,
to keep them on top of their court dates
and away from trouble.
But we've never let these projects grow.
Politics and profits
have always stamped out
the promise of freedom.
We can lock up migrants,
but we don't have to.
Instead of hoping
that barbed wire and steel doors
will guide us out of the labyrinth
of immigration law,
we could invest in justice.
We could make sure that every migrant
has a fair chance of putting
their best legal case forward.
Because immigration prisons
don't get us out of a problem.
Immigration prisons are the problem.
(Cheers and applause)
They blind us to the past,
when we did things differently,
and they distract us
from the moneymaking tentacles
that tie our future to the prison gates.
Well, the thing is,
liberty is too precious
for any of us to lose it
because politicians want votes
and private corporations want money.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)